[Musique]
ils sont des milliers déployés chaque
jour en France leur mission surveiller
dissuader protéger la population la
force centimètre quand ils sont présents
les gens sont plus en sécurité moi ça me
rassure énormément je me sens quand même
plus en sécurité opération militaire
créée en 2015 pour lutter contre la
menace terroriste sur le territoire
national sentinelle a montré son
efficacité lors de plusieurs attentats à
Orly à Marseille à Strasbourg
découvrons la ville d'un régiment de sa
préparation à son déploiement et
rencontrons ses hommes qui ont su avec
son froid réagir face à la menace
[Musique]
je suis le maréchal biology Sarah ça
fait quatre ans que je suis réserviste
au 4e chasseur à Gap et j'ai 22 ans en
tant que réserviste la mission
sentinelle c'est la mission la plus
concrète qu'on puisse avoir car c'est la
mission où on est le plus au contact de
la population donc c'est un peu
l'aboutissement de notre engagement
un service pour partir en sentinelle est
formé lors de la mise en conditions
opérationnel une fois qu'il a été jugé
apte par notre commandant d'unité
tout au long de l'année il va revalider
ses acquis pour pouvoir partir en
mission au coup de sifflet du régiment
[Musique]
on va aller voir mes gars qui sont en
pleine séance de tir pour se préparer à
partir à sentinelle
bonjour les gars ça va
bon ce matin vous allez faire les tirs
de gilets par balle et le tire-toc que
vous connaissez puisque vous l'avez déjà
fait ok allez on va aller voir ceux qui
sont déjà là-bas
sentier c'est pas une contrainte c'est
la mission voilà c'est notre mission
celle de protéger nos concitoyens que ce
soit sur le territoire national ou à
l'extérieur donc ça rentre dans le cadre
de notre de notre préparation
opérationnelle on s'entraîne pour partir
à sentinelle avec quelques modules
spécifiques liés à cet engagement
particulier puisqu'il a lieu sur le
territoire national mais c'est notre
mission bonjour les gars j'espère que ça
va Lucas oui très bien le tiers se passe
bien oui très bien on a on a une séance
là qui a une une série qui a déjà qui a
déjà terminé son tir donc son module les
soldats de sentinelles sont formés au
secourisme et entraînés aux techniques
de combat pour pouvoir neutraliser un
adversaire sans tirer
ils sont rodés à l'usage des armes et à
leurs règles d'emploi des compétences
indispensables contrôlées avant chaque
départ en mission la prochaine
série sonne et on se retrouve sur le pas
de cirque
quatrième position tire debout sur deux
cibles masculins
[Musique]
c'est 5 missions sentinelles depuis que
je me suis engagé
moi je suis chef de groupe sur
sentinelle donc j'ai cette personne sous
mes ordres dans mon adjoint je prends
mes ordres auprès de mon chef de peut-on
donc pour tout ce qui concerne les
patrouilles et on garde une certaine
autonomie directement sur le terrain
donc là trois semaines du départ je suis
prêt je suis prêt à effectuer ma mission
on est préparé ça permet quand même de
passer les fêtes de fin d'année avec la
famille donc c'est un grand point
positif pour repartir opérationnel en
janvier
c'est la dernière cérémonie de l'année
qui est un temps fort pour le régiment
et pour le chef de corps c'est la
dernière fois qu'il va voir son régiment
complet avant que chacun parte sur ses
missions dont l'escadron qui va partir à
sentinelle
[Musique]
regardez-moi ici
là nous sommes à l'arbre de Noël du
régiment qui revêt cette année un
caractère tout particulier puisque donc
on est quelques jours avant le départ en
permission et au retour de ces
permissions tous les cadran va partir à
sentinelle en mission sentinelle à Paris
donc c'est le dernier moment où on se
retrouve en famille originaux sur le
lieu de travail les enfants peuvent
venir voir leur papa en uniforme donc
voilà c'est un sens très particulier
cette année
tu reviennes quand il part
qu'il revienne et on essaye de donner un
parce que du coup bah elle a besoin
quand mon papa il part parce que j'ai
très peur pour lui bonjour enchaîner
autant de mission sur le territoire
national et à l'extérieur ça représente
une exigence particulière sur le plan de
la préparation opérationnelle
individuelle et collective et puis
également sur le plan de l'équilibre
familial parce qu'on demande beaucoup à
nos hommes mais je dirais c'est le
métier qu'on a tous choisi et pour
lequel on s'entraîne au quotidien
sentinelle a renforcer l'ancrage local a
remis les soldats dans les rues visibles
de leurs concitoyens et a permis aux
militaires de protéger plus concrètement
plus directement sur le territoire
national la population française
sentinelle vise à protéger la population
contre les attaques terroristes cette
opération existe depuis les attentats de
2015 pourtant depuis bien longtemps nous
voyons les militaires patrouillés dans
les rues opération sentinelle plan
Vigipirate quelle différence depuis les
années 90 on a un dispositif de réaction
aux attentats en France qui s'appelle
Vigipirate et qui est un plan
interministériel qui demande des moyens
à l'ensemble des ministères dont les
armées et en 2015 après les attentats
Charlie Hebdo la nécessité d'avoir une
présence plus importante de militaires
sur le territoire national a mené à la
création d'une nouvelle opération qui
s'appelle sentinelle qui est la réponse
militaire à la menace terroriste sur le
territoire national
sentinelle et donc le volet militaire de
l'opération Vigipirate elle est dirigée
par un organe central le CPCO le champ
de planification est conduite des
opérations c'est le centre de crise des
armées il gère l'ensemble des opérations
l'armée française dont les opérations
sur le territoire national alors
concrètement au CPCO pour sentinelle on
essaie de faire exprimer au ministère
intérieur ce dont ils ont besoin et on
nous on le traduit en mission militaire
et derrière ça on va définir en lien
avec les zones de défense en lien avec
le terrain quels sont les moyens
nécessaires pour remplir la mission que
nous est donnée par le ministère de
l'Intérieur donc le préfet rédige une
réquisition en disant je réquisitionne
les armées pour remplir tel tel mission
le 29 octobre 2020 après l'attentat de
Nice le président de la République
décide un renforcement du dispositif
antiterroriste sur le territoire j'ai
décidé que
nos militaires
seront dans les prochaines heures
davantage mobilisées et nous passerons
la mobilisation dans le cadre de
l'opération sentinelle de 3000 à 7000
militaires sur notre sol selon l'ampleur
de la menace le gouvernement décrète un
niveau d’alerte dont le plus élevé est
l'urgence attentat de ce niveau d’alerte
dépend la mobilisation de sentinelles
jusqu'à 10 000 soldats peuvent être
déployés pour protéger le pays après la
décision du Président de la République
d'augmenter les effectifs de sentinelle
en France il a fallu dans un premier
temps accueillir et équiper des unités
supplémentaires sur l'Île-de-France et
là aujourd'hui pendant la relève il y a
de l'ordre de 5000 soldats en entrée et
en sortie qui vont passer par la zone de
transit de Brétigny tous les deux mois
les unités se relèvent elle se croisent
sur la zone de transit pour restituer ou
percevoir le matériel nécessaire à leur
mission 45% des effectifs sont déployés
en Île-de-France contenu des enjeux vous
savez que en Île-de-France se trouve les
centres de pouvoir
une grande partie de la population et un
nombre important de sites sensibles
d'écoles de sites culturels etc
l'ensemble de ces effectifs transit par
une zone logistique avant qu'il ne
rallie leur zone de déploiement les
zones de déploiement se trouve au sein
de Paris intra-muros mais également
autour de Paris en petite couronne le
quatrième Régiment de Chasseurs de Gap
ragaillardi par les fêtes et prêt à
assurer sa mission sentinelle en
Île-de-France température contrôlée en
raison de la crise sanitaire matériel
récupéré logement perçu les cavaliers de
montagne commenceront leur patrouille le
jour même
ça fait cinq ans que la mission
sentinelle les encours un certain nombre
de travaux ont été réalisés sur des
emprises militaires pour faire en sorte
que les gens puissent bénéficier de
conditions d'hébergement décentes dans
les conditions actuelles l'ensemble de
la force était bergées dans des
bâtiments en dur pour une durée de
mission dont je rappelle qu'elle est de
2 mois
qu'est-ce que d'habitude on est surtout
qu'on est des féminines on est toutes
les féminines d'enfants alors que là on
est deux du coup pour les horaires
différents ça va être
[Musique]
ça va être moins galère en fait et les
sanitaires dans la chambre c'est
vraiment bien aussi
il dispose et ça c'est un vrai progrès
depuis 2015 une carte qui est alimentée
journalièrement ici à Paris c'est de
l'ordre de 30 euros par personne pour
une journée bien entendu ce n'est pas
exclusif de la possibilité de se nourrir
dans des restaurants administratifs on a
recours également comme c'est le cas
dans les opérations extérieures de de
ration de combat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un des objectifs principaux de
l'opération sentinelle c'est la
dissuasion de la menace terroriste avoir
des soldats qui patrouillent en armes
dans nos grandes villes c'est pas anodin
c'est pas neutre vous devez avoir des
soldats entraînés à qui ira sur la
population parce que ils sont capables
d'intervenir dans un milieu complexe
dans un environnement urbain avec des
risques de dommages collatéraux
importants néanmoins nos soldats ont
cette entraînement ont cette capacité et
ils le vivent autant en opération
extérieure que sur le territoire
national ils sont entraînés à avoir la
meilleure réaction possible en fonction
de l'environnement et aussi de la menace
donc si vous voulez c'est une dissuasion
vis-à-vis de l'ennemi et en même temps
on va rassurer la population bonjour les
volontaires
centre ville de Marseille
l'accueil est plutôt bon en général
surtout en période de fête du coup les
gens sont pas trop de cadeaux pour
l'instant
un sourire on essaie d'avoir malgré les
masques merci bonne nuit bonne journée
les gens ont l'habitude de voir
sentinelle on va dire que sentinelle
fait partie du paysage même si c'est un
côté un peu inquiétant de voir des
militaires en armes dans les rues au
quotidien mais ça rassure ça rassure les
gens et les gens nous en sont
reconnaissants
le territoire français est divisé en 7
zones de défense dirigée chacune par un
officier général la zone sud commandée
par le général Housset couvre tout le
bassin méditerranéen à Marseille dans
les bureaux du général le centre
opérationnel chargé de mener l'opération
sentinelle veille en permanence
le quotidien de sentinelle c'est pas
intervenir c'est surtout de dissuader de
surveiller de rassurer
et par cette présence en fin de compte
on protège la population et si besoin
d'intervient alors il y a des règles
d'engagement qui sont extrêmement
claires c'est de la légitime défense
étendue à autrui mais c'est également la
possibilité d'arrêter un périple
meurtrier quand la personne s'en va
qu'elle fuit mais qu'elle est encore
armée et qu'on imagine que la personne
peut les continuer à tuer à côté même si
en fuite on a le droit de l'intercepter
par les moyens qui sont adaptés
proportionnelles
mais quelqu'un qui tue et qui n'obéit
pas aux injonctions et aux sommations de
la force où il faut la neutraliser avant
qu'elle tue d'autres personnes donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé vers
Saint-Charles
13h45 le premier octobre 2017
un terroriste vient d'attaquer deux
jeunes femmes à l'arme blanche sur le
parvis de la gare de Marseille un
réserviste du Premier Régiment étranger
de génie en patrouille sentinelle lui
fait face
quelques minutes après te avoir pris ma
place des civils sont arrivés en courant
demandant où étaient les militaires
qu'il fallait absolument aller sur le
parvis il se passer quelque chose mais
j'avais pas plus d'infos que ça
je me suis dit ça a l'air quand même
urgent donc toute façon en quittant mon
poste mon chef de groupe ne me voyait
plus donc il sait qu'il se passe quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'il vienne je me suis
dirigé vers le parvis vers où les civils
indiquées qui se passait quelque chose
là j'ai vu
une personne au sol plus une personne à
genoux dessus
la première idée qui vient c'est pas
c'est pas qui se passe
un attentat c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
un malaise il y avait une bagarre la
personne qui est au-dessus porte secours
ou essaye de voir qu'est-ce qui se passe
je me suis avancé vers eux et en
arrivant à une dizaine de mètres j'ai
demandé qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui se
passe
là la personne qui était au dessus c'est
retourné m'a vu c'est relevé agrandi un
couteau et a commencé à courir vers moi
je lui ai dit de s'arrêter forcément je
fais mes sommations et voyant qui
continue à courir vers moi avec son
couteau en l'air charme je vise et je
tire j'ai pas je j'ai pas le temps de me
demander qu'est-ce qu'il fait pourquoi
ensuite je suis passé à côté de lui j'ai
vu qu'il n'avait rien il avait sa veste
qui était ouverte il y avait pas de
ceinture ou autre parce que là ça change
complètement d'optique c'est plus dans
le sens où il y a eu une bagarre et
j'interviens c'est quelqu'un qui a
essayé de m'attaquer est-ce qu'il est
tout seul est-ce que est-ce que la
personne il était dessus est blessé
mon chef de groupe est
les autres collègues étaient derrière
moi je me suis avancé vers la première
victime j'ai vu que c'était terminé pour
elle et j'ai entendu des bruits je me
suis tourné j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
deuxième victime qui était encore en vie
des civils qui l'ont pris en compte
donc moi j'ai pu réintégrer le
dispositif parce que du coup on a fait
toute une sécurisation au niveau du
parvis de la gare Charles
donc réserviste on est formé pour pour
partir sur des missions sentinelles on
voit le plus de possibilités possible
lors des entraînements le réflexe que
j'ai eu à Marseille je l'ai eu parce que
j'ai fait mes formations avant et oui ça
donne encore envie de continuer parce
que justement on se dit que c'est utile
ça sert quand vous êtes sur un théâtre
d'opérations extérieures c'est le
régiment c'est le groupement tactique
c'est le secours comment tactique la
sentinelle c'est la section et le groupe
de combat
donc c'est le sergent qui est tout seul
ou avec son équipe et c'est eux qui
réagissent donc c'est eux qui doivent
prendre les bonnes décisions tout de
suite et là ça révèle les quelques fois
des comportements actuellement héroïques
comme dirait notre rappeur marseillais
soprano ce sont des héros nos héros du
quotidien
et oui les gars qui ont été là à ce
moment-là parfaitement bien réagi ils
ont fait ce qu'ils avaient à faire de
manière extrêmement professionnelle
[Musique]
l'histoire et l'espoir fleurit à tous
ces héros
[Musique]
leur dire
à Marseille à Orly à Strasbourg ils ont
sauvé des vies les militaires de
sentinelles ne sont pas une force de
police ils en sont un soutien l'attentat
de Strasbourg en fut une autre
illustration si sont le premier sur le
lieu de l'attentat donc là ils vont
premièrement réagir à l'attentat c'est
un attentat armé ils vont avoir une
utilisation proportionnelle de la force
en même temps ils font prévenir les FSI
et ils vont gérer l'événement et
protéger la population et c'est ensuite
les policiers ou les gendarmes qui vont
reprendre à leur compte l'opération
lors du 11 décembre 2018 avec mon
quadrinome en fait on était en
patrouille dans l'hypersens de
Strasbourg enfin sécuriser les marchés
de Noël lors de notre déplacement au
loin on a vu un mouvement de foule avec
des gens qui crient la soirée commence
on accueille nos premiers clients et au
fur et à mesure que la soirée avance on
commence à on a des grandes baies
vitrées donc on commence à avoir à
l'extérieur des gens qui courent si
c'est là qu'on a vu qu'il y a quelque
chose parce qu'il se retourner vous êtes
sur cette peur que quelqu'un en cours
après donc on se rapprochant assez
rapidement de la zone les gens sont
venus nous voir directement pour nous
dire que dans une des ruelles à
proximité il y avait un homme armé qui
tirait sur la population au même moment
on entend des coups de feu donc avec mon
quadrinome on est parti tout de suite en
avant donc en faisant reculer le maximum
de personnes en disant aux gens de fuir
et des gens viennent se réfugier chez
nous on panique en nous disant restant
il y a un attentat il y a un attentat ça
tire ça tire donc nous on a on a
accueilli les gens on est des amis en
sécurité on s'est retrouvé à moins de 50
mètres du terroriste donc il avait une
victime à ses jambes dès qu'il nous a vu
il a fait feu un de mes soldats a reçu
une balle dans son FAMAS ce qu'il a
projeté au sol mon deuxième soldat a eu
la présente d'esprit de riposter
immédiatement ce qui a permis à son
notre collègue de se relever et pouvoir
se mettre à l'abri donc A2 ils ont
commencé à maintenir le feu je me
rappelle toujours d'une jeune fille qui
est venue avec son avec son compagnon on
était
tétanisé il a fallu que je lui parle que
je la sois je l'accompagne je dise
écouter ça va aller oui mais il y a la
porte c'est vitré je fais non là vous
êtes en bas vous êtes en partie basse
même endroit que nous on avait encore
quelques personnes civiles qu'on garde
derrière les murs de façon à ce que eux
ne puisse pas partir tout de suite pour
pas prendre une balle une balle perdue
comme caporal onzin a réussi à le
blesser au bras à ce moment-là les FSI
donc la police sont arrivés sur notre
position donc ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'on est monté à l'assaut jusqu'à la
position
initiale du tireur qui lui entre temps
avait eu la présence d'esprit de de
partir donc là on a pu sécuriser la zone
et c'est d'apporter les premiers soins à
la victime qui elle avait pris plusieurs
coups de couteau et qui était au sol la
force sentinelle qui est passée à
plusieurs reprises par groupe de 4 il
montait il descendait il faisait des
allers-retour tout simplement c'est fort
sentinelles sont restés jusqu'au bout
mais moi qui ai fermé à une heure du
matin quand je suis pris la voiture je
suis descendu elles ont assuré leur rôle
de sécurité tout au long quoi pour le
coup j'étais assez satisfait même
carrément satisfait de mes hommes
d'ailleurs parce que ok on a perdu
l'esprit tout le monde est resté un gars
de son froid mon chef d'équipe a fait
son travail nickel c'est à dire qu'elle
a géré les tirs pendant que moi je
devais rendre compte à mes supérieure il
y a pas eu de stress et mais personne
n'ont tiré correctement dans le sens où
c'était visé ils ont pas tiré n'importe
comment le premier qui ont été au
contact mais en face à face parce que la
la patrouille la patrouille arrivait
dans le cadre de sa ronde classique
c'était les effectifs sentinelles qui se
sont retrouvés face à lui il les a
engagés tout de suite c'est à dire qu'il
leur a tiré dessus tout de suite et eux
ont riposté et c'est là qu'il a été
blessé dans le contexte on était
toujours avec une menace potentielle
dans la nature
et ça ça a duré jusqu'au jeudi soir donc
moment où une patrouille de la sécurité
publique l'occasion d'un contrôle tombé
sur le mise en cause leur attiré dessus
ils ont riposté et ils l'ont neutralisé
les enseignements qu'on a pu tirer sur
la nécessité d'échanges d'information de
terrain permis de développer certains
process notamment le fait d'avoir des
salles de commandement commune
où les infos se donnent en direct dans
les deux sens parce que c'est pas
uniquement de l'armée vers la police
c'est aussi de la police vers l'armée et
ça maintenant je veux dire c'est devenu
un acquis au quotidien le Sentinel c'est
une opération en appui des forces de
sécurité intérieure donc à chaque niveau
nous devons discuter planifier
travailler avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur ensuite au niveau des
régions vous avez les officiers généraux
de zone de défense qui travaillent avec
les préfets de région et qui détermine
quels sont les centres principaux de
menaces dans les régions et enfin ça
tout ça s'est mis en oeuvre au niveau
des département avec d'un côté le préfet
de département de l'autre le délégué
militaire départemental et ça on peut le
décliner jusqu'au niveau des patrouilles
vous avez la patrouille sentinelle qui
est complémentaire du travail que peut
faire une patrouille de police leur
action est coordonnée et ce qui est
certain c'est comme sentinelle n'a pas
de pouvoir judiciaire elle est en
contact permanent avec un officier de
police judiciaire pour pouvoir
intervenir sur un événement particulier
vous êtes en quadrinome toi et toi vous
passez en tête toi et moi on est
derrière
vous prenez vos espaces moi en fonction
de l'influence et d'habitude depuis un
mois Sarah la jeune réserviste du
quatrième chasseur de Gap a revêtu son
gilet par balle et assure sa mission de
chef de groupe son commandant d'unité le
capitaine Olivier fait la tournée de ses
équipes
chaque unité donc avec un capitaine à sa
tête à une zone de manœuvre donc quand
il prend en compte sa zone il prend en
compte ces menaces il prend en compte
l'environnement et il crée sa manœuvre
donc sa manoeuvre elle est dynamique non
prédictible et de couvrir un espace
assez important et c'est toute la
finesse du travail du capitaine sur le
terrain
j'ai régulièrement des points de
situation qui me remontent par par
l'échelle de groupe puis les chefs de
section pour moi me donner un aperçu le
plus concret possible et me permettre
tactiquement de réajuster mes
patrouilles les horaires afin de
récolter aussi un petit peu de
renseignements sur sur ce qui se passe
là où les menaces vont grandir donc on
surveille
le plus gros risque pour nous c'est que
qui une baisse de vigilance et c'est
pour ça je on fait souvent un rappel il
faut toujours rester concentré toujours
avant les bons réflexes pour que la
mission se passe bien
sur les points vigilants ça fait
beaucoup attention à la population en
général on essaie de déceler des regards
filants des actions suspectes des
comportements qui pourraient nous
interpeller et qui pourraient pas être
anormal
[Musique]
je pense qu'il vient de mon groupe ils
sont ils sont au top ils sont très
appliqués très concentrés très dans la
mission et il y a un temps pourri et un
temps pour travailler ils arrivent à
faire à la perfection à la différence et
je suis vraiment très contente de très
contente du goût et je repartirai très
volontiers avec eux sur une prochaine
mission sentinelle c'est la caméra
on rigole quand il faut rigoler on sera
on travaille quand il faut travailler ça
se passe très très bien
très intéressante parce qu'on est
vraiment au contact direct de la
population c'est très humain comme
expérience et c'est très valorisant
aussi
c'est très sécurisant ils font du bon
travail et comme on les voit dans
plusieurs lieux publics c'est vraiment
c'est bien s'il y aura un attentat aussi
qui sont là quoi et en plus ça nous
rassure parce que il y a beaucoup de
passants qui vont travailler ou quoi et
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver à un
moment à l'autre donc si bien de
toujours avoir des militaires quelque
part ou de la police quelque part pour
nous protéger à chaque fois que je
marche dans la rue je vois au moins une
patrouille ça permet de se sentir se
sentir bien quand on est dans la rue et
de se dire que ça va pas se reproduire
ici
je pense qu'il faut un métier aussi
important parce que suite aux attentats
c'est rassurant comme présence même si
on ne devrait pas en arriver là d'avoir
des gens comme ça autour de nous qui
sont capables de nous protéger ça me
semble utile à ce qu'il soit présent en
centre-ville effectivement ça me rassure
maintenant ça me permet de penser aussi
qu'on est toujours en zone rouge disons
moi ça me rassure énormément je me sens
quand même plus en sécurité de les voir
je suis toujours attentive maintenant
aux gens
on sait jamais ce qui peut se passer en
fin de compte oui ça me rassure
énormément bonjour
je voulais vous remercier parce que vous
faites actuellement pour nous
aujourd'hui de la situation avec le
colis des participes lors des attentats
aussi merci beaucoup merci beaucoup très
gentil à vous merci bonne journée à vous
bonne soirée
revoir